عاد الجدل من جديد الى الواجهه بين موسكو
والغرب بشان من يقف وراء هذه العمليه
فبعدت سته اشهر من الحادثه يتبادل الطرفان
الاتهامات ولكن المسؤول لا يزال مجهول
اذا في صفحات هذا التصعيد المستمر بين
الغرب وموسكو حول تفجير خط نورت ستريم
ياتي اخر صفحات هذا التراشق الدبلوماسي مع
عودتي نظريه التورط الاوكراني في
التفجيرات قباله جزيره بورن هولم
الدنماركيه في سبتمبر الماضيه طبعا هذه
الاتهامات وهذه المره جاءت نقلا عن تقارير
استخباراتيه امريكيه واوروبيه وجهت اصابع
الاتهام طبعا الى جماعه مؤيده لاوكرانيا
مع ذلك اكد مسؤولون امريكيون انهم لا
يملكون دليلا على تورط زيلينسكي او كبار
مساعديه في الهجمات لاحقا نفى وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني اوليكسي ريزنكوف مسؤوليه بلاده
عن الحادث في المقابل اعلنت متحدثه المدعي
العام الالماني ان النيابه الالمانيه قامت
بتفتيش سفينه يحتمل في تورطها في
التفجيرات في يناير الماضي مشيره الى انه
لا توجد بعد معلومات مؤكده حول الد او
ماهيه من قام بالتخطيط للعمل التخريبي لكن
صحيفه
الالمانيه اشارت الى ان القارب الذي تم
العثور عليه تم استئجاره من قبل اوكرانيين
او بالاحرى اوكرانيين اثنين من شركه ومقر
هذه الشركه بولندا العمليه نفذها فريق
كوماندوز اوكراني مؤلف من سته اشخاص من
بينهم سيده نقلوا المتفجرات على القارب
ابحروا من ميناء روستوك بالمانيا طبعا كل
هذا بحسب الصحيفه لم يتاخر رد موسكو حيث
قال الكرملين ان التقارير الاخيره هدفها
تحويل الانتباه عن الفاعل بالطبع كيف بحسب
روايه موسكو وتساءل بسكوف كيف يمكن
للولايات المتحده افتراض اي شيء حول
الهجمات بدون تحقيق
من يقف وراء تفجير خطي انابيب نور ستريم
صحيفه ديدسايت الالمانيه كشفت ان محققين
دوليين عثروا على القارب الذي استخدم
لتفخيخ انابيب نوت ستريم وان منفذي
العمليه فريق كوماندوس اوكراني
الحكومه الالمانيه اكدت ان التحقيق
المشترك مع الدنمارك والسويد بشان تفجير
نورت ستريم مستمر ولم يصل لنتيجه بعد
صحيفه كشفت عن تقييم للاستخبارات
الامريكيه اشاره الا ان مجموعه اوكرانيه
نفذت الهجوم على خطوط
العام الماضي
التقرير الذي يتحدث عن تورط اوكرانيا
بالتفجير نوتس ريم يبرر طلب موسكو اجراء
تحقيق مستقل بهذا الشان هذا ما قاله مندوب
روسيا الدائم لدى الامم المتحده فاسليا
من جانبها اعلنت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ان
كياث غير متورطه على الاطلاق في الاعتداء
على خطي انابيب
ولا معلومات لديها عما حدث